at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking question is discovered
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton
I love peloton peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right to your home you
don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule making it to
the studio or dealing with some commute
to the gym I have a peloton bike in my
master bedroom at home and it is one of
the first things that I do in the
morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually look forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do so
you have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride it live with thousands
of other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboard
to keep you motivated I tend to use a
lot of the classes on demand and have
four to six of them that I've bookmarked
and use over and over again there are up
to 14 new classes every day with
thousands of classes on demand and there
are a variety of workouts to choose from
45 minute classes 20 minute burns hip
hop rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style there works for you
peloton has an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
they really do have great instructors of
every possible personality and style and
you can find one that you love no matter
what you're in the mood for personally I
use Matt wolbers a lot but I use a bunch
of them I'm promiscuous and enjoy
classes from a lot of their instructors
with real time metrics you can track
your performance over time and continue
to beat your personal bests
I did not think the gamification would
work for me and they really hit the nail
on the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to do experience to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
pod
a limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that spelled o-n-e PE l oto n calm
enter the code
Tim podcast all one word at checkout and
get $100 off accessories with your
peloton bike purchase get a great
workout at home anytime you want go to
one peloton calm and use the code tim
podcast to get started this episode of
the tim ferriss show is brought to you
by 99 designs 99 designs is a global
creative platform that makes it easy for
you to find an amazing designer and
create designs you'll love from logos to
branding to packaging to books you name
it they have it and I've used them for
just about everything 99 designs is the
go to creative resource for any budget
I've used them for years now for book
covers for instance mock-ups
of the 4-hour body which went on to
become a number one New Times bestseller
illustrations for the multi volume Tao
of Seneca including the cover and many
other creative projects have been very
impressed by the quality of their work
most recently I used 99 designs to
update the illustrations and layout of
my five morning rituals eBook the
illustrations worked out great I loved
working with the designer we selected
and I plan to work with him on more
projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the world will
submit concepts for you to choose from
you refined as you go give feedback and
once you're ready you choose one to
finalize it's a great way to get started
and find the right match a great
designer and a great design at a great
price so head to 99 designs com forward
slash Tim to learn more or get started
today you can also see examples of some
of the work that I have done with
designers online and designs let's check
it out 99 designs comm forward slash tip
why hello boys and girls
Damas Y Caballeros this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to sit
down
with world-class performers of all
different types to tease out the habits
routines favorite books etc and so on ad
infinitum ad nauseam so that you can
apply and test them in your own life
this time we have a different format I
will not be the one doing the
deconstructing instead we have a
takeover by Mike maples jr. an old and
close friend of mine so who is this Mike
maples jr. Mike and his firm floodgate
have invested in and supported many of
the startups
you might recognize and many of them are
no longer startups they are publicly
traded companies including Twitter and
then you got all these big names like
twitch lyft Chegg and octa among others
long before they were household names
he's put on the Forbes Midas list eight
times in the last decade but he's much
more than a successful investor of
course I would be enough by itself but
mike has also succeeded as both a
founder and operating executive he's
also simply a great guy and the first
person who really taught me how to angel
invest a hundred years ago and I first
moved to Silicon Valley for more on that
background if you're interested listen
to my interview with mike at tim dot
blog forward slash Mike maples in this
episode however Mike speaks with Andy
rackleff co-founder of wealth front
benchmark capital about two of the
biggest questions that should be on
every startup founders mind one how do
you reach product market fit which is a
term that Andy coined and two how do you
know when you've achieved it and this
episode is really strong it's a very
strong conversation and includes many
examples in heuristics for how not to
fool yourself and how easy it is to fool
yourself and Andy has known many of the
start-up world's Giants and synthesized
their lessons so you will also hear what
Andy has learned from Don Valentin of
Sequoia Scott cook of Intuit Reed
Hastings of Netflix Jeffrey Moore clay
Christensen Eric Ries and Steve Blank
for example the audio from this
conversation is from the premiere
episode of Mike's brand-new podcast
which have been trying to get him to do
for a long time so I'm thrilled that
it's finally coming out called start
greatness which I highly recommend you
check out there are some very incredible
guests coming so if you like this
conversation between Mike and Andy be
sure to subscribe to start and greatness
on Apple podcast or wherever you get
your podcasts you can also check out the
website at greatness dot floodgate comm
and you can follow mike say hello on the
interwebs at m2 junior that's his
Twitter handle at M the number-two Jay
are starting greatness the podcast I
just mentioned will offer lessons from
the startups super performers and
feature interviews with some of Silicon
Valley's most legendary entrepreneurs
including netscape co-founder marc
andreessen LinkedIn founder Reed Hoffman
next door co-founder Sarah Leary and
more again that's starting greatness and
you can subscribe on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen to podcasts enjoy if
the customer doesn't scream you don't
have product market fit that's the voice
of Andy Radcliffe the person credited
with coining the term product market fit
and since getting product market fit is
vital to a raw startup we thought we'd
get straight to it and talk to him this
is Mike maples jr. of floodgate and it's
go time with Andy Radcliffe
[Music]
welcome to starring greatness and
podcast dedicated to ambitious founders
who want to go from nothing to awesome
superfast when you're a start-up founder
you have to channel your inner James
Bond your MacGyver your Wonder Woman I'm
gonna help you win by curating the
lessons of the super performers but
before they were successful
so without further ado ignition sequence
time let's get started in 1995 Andy
Radcliffe co-founded the firm benchmark
capital widely acknowledged to be one of
the best VC firms in Silicon Valley with
some of the best startup investments of
all time he's also a co-founder and CEO
of wealthfront so his ideas about
product market fit and startup success
are just academic and speaking of
academics and he also teaches the
renowned class at Stanford Business
School aligning startups with their
markets he literally is the professor of
product market fit let's catch up with
him
[Music]
Andy Radcliffe thanks for joining our
podcast thank you for having me Andy one
of the reasons that I was excited to
talk to you was to talk about the idea
product market fit which is probably one
of the most famous descriptors of what a
zero to 1 startup is trying to get to
where did that term come from in the
first place and what's the origin story
I can tell you the origin story of the
concept I learned it from Sequoia
Capital the Don Valentine really
invented it ok Dom used to say I I'm
looking to invest in companies that can
screw everything up and still succeed
because the customer pulls the product
out of their hands I'm paraphrasing I'm
not sure I got that exactly right
he felt that way because the startup
will screw everything up so I want if I
want a company that has such demand from
the market that they can literally screw
everything up and still succeed I
actually define it in terms used by
Steve Blank and Eric Ries they were the
first to apply the scientific method to
business and I think that Steve's great
contribution to the Entrepreneurship
business was the idea that first you
have to prove a value hypothesis and
only once you've proven the value I
pathi so should you test a growth
hypothesis to me product market fit is
when you have proven the value
hypothesis so the value I pathi says is
that what the WHO and the how what are
you gonna build for whom is it relevant
there how's the business model I get
this question a lot how do I know when I
have it I have four heuristics that I
use two for consumer and two for
enterprise okay so the two best consumer
ones that I know are exponential organic
growth people can gain growth and they
do it all the time and I'm always amazed
that people fall for it and that they
kid themselves into thinking they have
product market fit because they bought
it the only way to know is if that you
have product market fit is if you get
word of
I learned this from Scott cook who's the
best product guy that I've ever met and
so Scott was riveted on word-of-mouth
well the best test of word-of-mouth is
exponential organic growth because the
only way you can get exponential organic
growth is through word-of-mouth
the other heuristic that I suggest is
Net Promoter Score which is a proxy for
word-of-mouth it's not quite as good and
there are outliers where it just doesn't
work so sure mouth poly al-fatiha
who started the growth group at Facebook
once told me that at the height of
Facebook's growth their Net Promoter
Score was negative 14 so it's not always
an ideal indicator on the enterprise
side the the two that I suggest are one
that I learned from one of my teaching
partners at Stanford Marc Leslie who
created something called the sales
learning curve and now one of the the
metrics that Mark used and to determine
where in a company's life sales life it
was was by measuring the sales yield the
sales yield is the contribution margin
of a sales team divided by the total
cost to field the sales team so if you
have a direct sales rep an SAE an inside
sales rep and management overhead a
sales team might cost on the order of
five or six hundred thousand dollars not
until what mark in Chuck Holloway his
co-author of the paper that they
published on her in Harvard Business
Review found was that when a company
gets to a sales yield greater than one
that's how you know you've hit product
market fit that's to me the best test of
enterprise product market fit the other
one I learned from Doug Leonie of
Sequoia all my best ideas have come from
other people I just put an iterative
wisdom exactly and so Doug who is one of
the best noses for product market fit of
anyone that I've ever met taught me an
amazing lesson when
sat on one of our boards together and
that was every Enterprise company has to
do a proof-of-concept trial in order to
make these trials as productive as
possible companies typically require
that they be limited to 30 days and that
the customer sign a contract that says
if the product does what you represent I
will buy it after 30 days no company
ever lives up to that contract as you've
experienced right so what Doug suggests
is at the end of 30 days you pull the
trial no matter what if the customer
doesn't scream you don't have product
market fit because if they're not gonna
buy it at the end of the 30 days they're
not desperate and if you're not
desperate you don't have product market
fit Steve Blank in his book four steps
to the Epiphany conjures an image of the
customer reaching across the table and
grabbing you by the collar saying when
can I have this yeah I need this
yeah I've even I've wanted this I've
tried to do this more money on even
better I've already spent money trying
to do this myself
yeah so it's interesting because I think
there are two counterintuitive lessons
right one is a lot of founders when they
pitch early customers they want to feel
that their idea gets validated and they
sometimes don't see that you're trying
to find people who are in on the secret
with you right that that's the real goal
is to find the limited subset of people
who are in on the secret with you you
could go talk to those other folks later
but don't waste a lot of Ergas of energy
but the but the other thing that I think
that this kind of reveals is it's not
necessarily bad if the customers built
what you view as a competitive offering
that's great exactly it's so it's
counterintuitive because you'd think
well it's gonna be hard to close this
customer because I have competition here
but precisely the opposites true they've
progressed down the idea maze far enough
to know that they've been waiting for
you some of the most successful
enterprise software companies actually
were spinouts of products that companies
built for themselves but they couldn't
maintain them you know it's really funny
the the biggest want the second biggest
mistake that I see on
make especially an enterprise is that
when they pitched a potential customer
on the idea and the potential customer
doesn't like the idea then they try to
iterate on the product to build
something the customer would want and by
definition that's right in consensus so
it's gonna lead to a mundane outcome
that's the absolute wrong thing to do
even though that feels right so you want
to go find people who actually love what
you're doing not try to convince the
nose and turn them into yeses yeah and
you want them to be saying when is our
next meeting what is our next step how
are we gonna make progress on this come
back tomorrow I wanted to have my boss
Bob here but I didn't know I didn't know
what you're really doing I want you on
it by the way this is analogous to how
to attract a venture capitalist as well
if the venture capitalist doesn't
immediately say when can I meet you
again you haven't found product market
that's right yeah and it's funny to me
like the best startup scenarios I've
seen are when the the entrepreneur the
early investors and the early customers
are all in on a secret together they're
starting a movement that the rest of the
world will one day accept but they're
starting it as rebels right they're
starting it as people who are gonna
prove to the rest of the world that
their inside is right that is they
haven't caught up there's a book that
I've heard you reference recently that
it seems like people have forgotten
about and maybe they should put more
front and center which is crossing the
chasm why do you think that is what what
why do you think crossing the chasm is
current for today's world and should be
read by more folks well the fundamental
idea expressed in crossing the chasm is
there is a natural rate of adoption of
every product that hasn't changed that
was true a hundred years ago and it's
going to be true in another 100 years
the basic premise is that there are
different people who are willing to
adopt two different rates by the way
those people change over time but
putting aside the
the lunatic fringe of the innovators are
the first people who adopt products are
the early adopters these people are our
revolutionary not evolutionary they want
to buy a product to solve their problem
and all they need is a proof-of-concept
in order to do it and if they get a
proof-of-concept they're gonna buy on
the merits of the product they have a
problem they're desperate they're
willing to buy next come the pragmatists
the pragmatists only buy they want
something that's evolutionary not
revolutionary they're not trying to get
ahead in their jobs they're trying not
to get fired and they'll only buy if
five people tell them they should buy so
it doesn't matter how well you serve
their needs they're not going to buy
until they get references they need
social proof the next group the
Conservatives or the late majority as
Jeffrey Moore the earth author calls
them only buy once it's become the
standard and then finally over the
laggards who don't bought now the
biggest chunk of the market is
represented by the pragmatists or the
early majority which leads most
entrepreneurs to go after them first but
there's a catch-22
how can you go after them first if you
don't have any references the biggest
problem by far the biggest mistake I see
people make is trying to start with the
pragmatists because it's the biggest
market because every podcast you listen
to or every book written on
entrepreneurship says you should go
after a big market because ultimate size
of market addressed is the single
greatest deterrent outcome which is true
but you're not going to capture that
market if you try to start with that
market and this lesson will last forever
I often get asked well if your product
is so great why doesn't everyone use it
because it takes a while for you to
transition from early adopters to the
early majority to the late majority of
the latter a lot of times I find it
interesting people will bring up
so-called counter examples like Facebook
and those whiners yeah and also
Facebook started at Harvard actually
Facebook is a perfect example of the
crossing the chasm philosophy so they
solved a very very small problem which
is there was no common Facebook across
across the freshman class at Harvard it
was only by house so the only way you
could see who else was in the freshman
class was through the Facebook and then
it spread to some other Ivy League
schools because the kids at Dartmouth
and Yale had friends at Harvard and then
it spread to other colleges and then it
spread to high schools after that so it
exactly followed the crossing the chasm
ah it's not an outlier at all but I
often hear people try to find issue with
theories using examples and my teaching
partner for my product-market fit class
at Stanford is a fella named bill
Barnett who's a professor and one of the
great lessons I learned about teaching
from Bill is he does not allow students
to use examples and their arguments
because the example could be an outlier
so he asks the students to give me the
logic hmm and if you can't give the
logic you can't win the argument and and
and even I guess in the case of Facebook
then it feels like that was an example
where Mark Zuckerberg didn't say I
wonder what the market for social
networking is gonna be I think he was
solving his own problem here's the
problem as soon as the company becomes
successful that revises history because
people in the early majority want to
believe that the product was built for
them telling the story of how you
actually got there is off-putting so
every great marketer I know is a
revisionist here's another great example
Google so we all know about how it took
off as a search engine but as a business
it exactly followed the crossing the
chasm philosophy or the technology
adoption lifecycle when they first
started monetizing they used text ads
now at the time Yahoo
for display outs yahoo sold these ads
through a Salesforce so in order to
justify the cost of a sales call you had
to sign up to a minimum of $10,000 a
month contract for 6 or 12 months to
justify the cost of the sales call and
you also had to pay for a graphic artist
be back then we didn't have designers
and startups or in companies they were
contractors so you had to pay for a
graphic artist to design the display up
and that might cost three to five
thousand dollars so the minimum cost to
run an ad was 13 to $15,000 when Google
came to market with this six word text
ad they got the idea from overture but
it didn't matter but there this text ad
when they took it to people who did
display ads they said why would I a
picture is worth a thousand words why
would I pay for a text ad so you know
who the only people who bought the X
text ads were in the beginning yeah I
guess anybody who wasn't paying $6,000
starlighter's who can't afford it
yeah so they went to the desperate and
it only caught the you could get by an
ad for as little as $1 on your credit
card with a self-service process and
they got startups to sign up for it
they were the desperate now once they
prove the efficacy of text ads versus
display ads they cross the chasm into
the early majority and they got
references and they were able to grow
the market but they started with
startups they didn't start with
traditional advertising what I love
about that example is how it illustrates
ELLs that story because that's not what
you wanted to hear if you were a
tradition yeah if you're a pragmatist
buyer you want to be central and a
heroes narrative about you right not
about like the crazy wacky stuff you did
in the early days when you were trying
to find a small band of desperate people
who believe what you believe one of my
biggest challenges when I teach this
concept to my students is they've all
heard the revisionists story so they
don't believe me
and the storyteller has no incentive to
change the story so you're talking to
the the
voice of authority of that company
you're talking to the founder of the
company and he's saying this is my story
it's pretty hard - pretty hard to go
guess but like when you go back in time
I see this with some of the investments
that we made that worked out
it's easy to miss remember how it even
happened it's easy to not even
understand why you did something or why
it worked or you know what in fact what
a my favorite stories revised stories
that the founder actually never tells
himself or the CEO never tells himself
but everyone tells about him is the
story of Netflix so Netflix started as a
DVD rental by mail where you literally
paid $6 every time you rented and they'd
mail you another DVD and it failed
miserably
well Reed Hastings was the seed investor
he wasn't the founder of the company and
he was the chairman of the company one
of the big mistakes we talked about was
how people iterate on the what they
shouldn't but what you should iterate on
the WHO and the how the business model
so Reed ran a very successful technical
software comfortable prior to starting
Netflix I know this because I was on his
board her software writer software and
one of the things that redid to turn
pure into a very successful I think a
greater than hundred million dollar
revenue technical software company which
was very unusual at that time was he
changed the business model from
perpetual license to subscription
license that was really controversial in
the early 1990s when he stepped in to
take over Netflix because it was failing
he said well why don't we try the
subscription thing that might work and
little did he know it it was the ideal
antidote to the late fees that
blockbuster charge that used to drive
everyone crazy so Reed was trying to
find people are desperate at the time
you couldn't buy D you couldn't rent
DVDs you didn't have much of a selection
at Blockbuster stores so people were
desperate to get the DVDs but not at $6
per unit through the mail yeah the
this model allowed the desperate people
to do it now the story changed to read
was driving to Blockbuster to return a
movie one day and he passed his gym and
he thought why don't I apply the gym
business model to Blockbuster that's not
how it happened at all so that's that's
what he says now that's not what he says
but that's what the mark the the myth
became about Netflix ok rather than this
business ain't working I better try Plan
B and it sure worked which which is
probably a good way to think about
pivots in general right like how does
this thought process relate to pivots in
your mind you have to be willing to fail
but you don't pivot on the product if
you fix the market and pivot the product
then you have no advantage because your
original insight is gone so what
advantage do you have over anyone else
you're now in that writing consensus
Quadrant you have to try to find a
different market or a different business
model to enable people to buy your
product the technical insight that
underlies your product is usually what
you're betting the whole company on and
if that insight is invalid you're
probably better off just starting over
right you don't have a company you don't
have a now you're just out there just
selling whatever hoping for a miracle
exactly but I guess similar looks a Hail
Mary okay and so so then if I understand
correctly the valid definition of a
pivot is keep your insight keep your
proprietary insight but then find the
right customer for that existing insight
rather than abandon your insight don't
let go of your secret I don't believe
that everyone can apply the Lean Startup
methodology to succeed I think it
increases your odds of succeeding just
because you're pivoting on the market
doesn't mean you're gonna find a
desperate market but if you do you're
gonna build a much better business the
metaphor of pivot is apt and that a
pivot involves keeping your pivot foot
on the ground as you move your body
right and your gate in sight yeah and
your pivot grant your pivot foot has to
be the same right you can't you can't
have any arbitrary
aspect of success bigger pivot now there
are there are outliers there are
exceptions a great example is Instagram
ended up doing something completely
different
yeah than what it started out to do that
was not a pivot that was a restore well
it's funny and I was involved with a
company called Chegg which did textbook
rentals a complete restart we were out
of money and we'd had this idea and
Facebook decided to go into classifieds
and so we're like well we're out of
business if we're classifieds company so
let's let's try this textbook rental
idea that we've kind of had in the back
corner and we didn't have enough money
to do it but we thought all we have to
do is prove people rent textbooks and
we'll raise some but the the company was
fundamentally different from the idea
you know it was just an idea that we
tried out desperation so the vast
majority of successful startup
successful technology companies pivoted
from their original proposed market in
their business plan very very few
restarted yep there are exceptions but
that's why you shouldn't argue the
example you have to a lot argue the
logic which relates to a point I've
heard you make before not everybody
needs to like your product in fact it
may even be better if not everybody
likes your product what do you mean by
that it's actually the subject of the
first class in my product market fit
course which is not everyone should like
your idea or should everyone like your
idea and the answer is absolutely not so
let me give you some context first let
me offer a framework for thinking about
this that I learned from my investment
Idol a man named Howard Marks who's the
founder of a distressed debt investment
firm called oak tree capital he believes
that investing and I believe
entrepreneurship can be described with a
two-by-two matrix on one dimension you
can be right or wrong and on the other
dimension you can be consensus or non
consensus now what most people you know
obviously if you're wrong you don't make
money but what most people don't realize
is if you're right in consensus you
don't make money because the returns get
arbitrage dawei the only way to make
outsized returns as an investor or an
entrepreneur is to be right in
non-consensus the problem is you only
know that your non-consensus when you
start
not whether or not you're right you hope
you're right
unless you're non-consensus you don't
have a chance to serve the desperate
because they wouldn't be desperate if
they were already served now if you ask
five people on the street about your
idea which might be a killer idea at
least four out of the five of them
should say they don't like it because
they haven't been conditioned to like it
human beings are conditioned to like
things are not like things think of the
the greatest ideas in the last 10 years
uber if you asked 10 people on the
street about uber ride hailing service
they'd say why do I need that
that feels unsafe why don't we less
stranger or drive me around Airbnb would
I let somebody into my home to rent a
room that's crazy so you want people to
not like it if everyone likes the idea
that means they've already been
conditioned so you're trying to do a
better job of what somebody else has and
that is not a recipe for success in
technology you you talked earlier about
Scott cook and being the best product
guy you knew I've also heard you use the
term savored surprises I think that's a
really good good a good framing
principle so can you talk about that a
little bit sure that's something that I
learned from Scott one of the best parts
of teaching is how much you get to learn
and we are really fortunate being here
in Silicon Valley that we can write
cases about companies and then have the
protagonist of the case actually come to
the class to discuss what happened and
not give you the revised history but
tell you what actually happened and so
I'm incredibly fortunate to have taught
a couple of classes where Scott was the
guest he was the protagonist of the case
and yes and one of the amazing lessons
that I learned from him was a concept
that is a core part of the intuit
culture now which is to savor surprises
and by that they mean that whenever you
create a new product and bring it to
market either as a Minimum Viable
Product to a group of five users or to
or to a thousand
there's always going to be a surprise
something you didn't expect people to
react to positively or negatively and
Scott found that all of the value lies
in the surprise and it's and it's
interesting I've heard him say that in a
in another forum which was so we were on
a panel together once it South by
Southwest and he brought this up and he
said that when he's in a meeting
and somebody's proposing a big project
or a launch or a new initiative he would
ask well as you did this analysis and
work what surprised you and what he what
he learned was that if if the people
couldn't answer that question they were
really just trying to get their agenda
across they were just really trying to
get money for their pet project but but
how could you possibly have a market
discovery or customer discovery exercise
where nothing surprised you right like
how could that how could that ever make
sense the writing consensus quadrant if
you have which is death
yeah or you're you just weren't
listening to the market it's so where
where we internalized it was now when we
talk to people we say every iteration so
like every company in zero to one pre
product market fit mode we like to say
as an iteration tempo and so a consumer
product may iterate every day an
enterprise software company can't
deliver half a loaf to General Motors so
their tempo may be slower but we like to
say you must have savored surprises at
the end of every iteration or on some
level you wasted the iteration you
didn't you didn't gather any new urn
secrets in the engagement with a
customer you know our president at well
front as a great saying that the
definition of a good experiment is one
from which you learned not one that
succeeded right right so if there are no
surprises then you didn't learn anything
right it wasn't a good experiment
and when what was the biggest mistake
you made at wealthfront where you look
back on it and you're just like I should
have no III know that was unforced error
so number one was I ignored a lesson
that I teach my students Oh
over and over and over again which is
don't project your own tastes onto other
people this is an enormous mistake my
MBAs much they say well I wouldn't use
that product therefore it's not a good
company well you might not be the target
audience so that's irrelevant and as a
venture capitalist you know that's one
of the first things you have to unlearn
yep so I did that in terms of thinking
about the attractiveness of what we
initially offered and then the other
thing was the original implementation of
the idea was a marketplace where you
could choose investment managers who we
would apply the IV methodology to
determine who was likely to outperform
the market and we did a really good job
of picking the managers and nobody cared
and part of the problem was we applied
Steve blanks customer development
methodology to one side of the two-sided
marketplace but not to both sides
because adventure mark we had backed a
number of very successful marketplaces
or network effects business I had
effectively co-founded Equinix which is
now a multi-billion dollar so I seen
that firsthand we had open table we had
operating systems companies ready they
and they ran a ton of them and so what I
had learned from this experience was
that it's hard to catalyze a marketplace
so you tend to focus on the sell side
before the buy side
I even recruited Jeff Jordan who's now a
partner at Andreessen Horowitz who had
run eBay North America and and PayPal
and after he retired from eBay he
actually ran OpenTable another network
effects business marketplace and he
agreed that this was the right thing to
do so we spent all of our efforts
applying customer development to the
sell side and never to the buy-side
assuming that if we had the liquidity
that the buy side would just come that
was the dumbest thing I ever could have
done when did you have sort of the
Epiphany that oh I'm I'm I need to
remember some of my thinking on this
well we were
failing that get your attention we had
about 10 or 11 months of cash left in
the bank we work we were growing but we
weren't growing at the rate that would
get us another venture financing I knew
that we had to do something different
interestingly the night that I made the
decision I was reading a chapter of our
clay Christensen book that I was going
to talk about in my product market fit
class and it just hit me like a
sledgehammer that what we were doing
wasn't disruptive in the Christensen
definition it was better but better
doesn't matter and it was one of those
oh my god moments this makes no sense
and I'd been trying to get my VP of
Marketing to talk to people who started
a sign-up process but didn't follow
through to see why they didn't and one
of the challenges with Millennials and
forgive me for for saying as I'm 60
years old is that people in my
generation like to talk to people
Millennials don't this is the key to the
success of wealth fret by the way is our
clients pay us not to talk to them we
deliver a full suite of next generation
banking services and investment services
without having to talk to us about
anything everything's automated the
downside of it is they only want to look
at behavioral data or or email feedback
to make decisions and I knew we had to
get it out as Steve says you have to get
out of the effing building to talk to
customers so after six months of trying
to get my VP of Marketing to do it I was
a first-time CEO and I didn't want to
step in and tell her what to do because
that's not very empowering and finally I
said to hell with it I'm gonna start
calling these people myself and the
feedback they gave me was unbelievably
consistent which was we used to just
address the public equity portion of
your portfolio which is about a third
should be about a third of your money
and people said I'd rather that you
manage all of my money adequately and
inexpensively than a portion of its
superb one and how did you know your
early on actually it was a great it was
a crossing the chasm suggestion from one
of my angel investors again we had
started as this investment management
service so we had evolved it was it was
a pivot because 90% of the software was
the same instead of having a marketplace
of investment managers it was just us
that manager portfolio had a board
meeting before we launched the new
service and I said to my board members
people who are exposed to this loved it
but my biggest concern is that we have a
chicken-and-egg problem and that is
people don't know how to evaluate a
financial advisor so they use assets
under management as the proxy for
quality it's actually a terrible proxy
for quality it's a great proxy for how
good someone is excelling others not how
good they are at investing and so I'm
not quite sure what we're gonna do here
and Doug McKenzie who's a retired
partner of kleiner perkins who believed
in crossing the chasm because he's my
age said Andy why don't you focus on
young people in tech because they'll
care a lot more about the quality of the
user experience than they will the
assets under management and you and your
team have enough credibility in this
community that they'll take the early
adopters will take the the chat at the
proof of concept that was the critical
insight in the history of our company so
what do you do just call up people at
Facebook and say try this Facebook was
about six or twelve months away from IPO
a number of employees that sold
secondary stock we thought well who are
the best connected people in Silicon
Valley it's the people who work at the
social networks so we did three or four
seminars at Facebook and LinkedIn where
we educated people on investment best
practices net wealth front because we
wanted to get the engineer as the
earliest adopter
because we thought they would provide
the references to the less well-educated
people on investing and what we know
about engineers is they hate being sold
they're like cats they're not like dogs
those people are like dogs they want to
be patented headed and loved engineers
do not want to be sold to so we did this
beta test I'll never forget with Adam
D'Angelo of korah in a few people at
Quora and the beta test we did of the
seminar to eight people was 80%
education and 20% selling and at the end
of the seminar Adams said and you have
to decide which one it's going to be
because it can't be both and he was
absolutely right that was the surprise
so we went all education and immediately
Facebook and LinkedIn people signed up
and then use their networks to start
telling their friends how interesting
and then we learned that employees of
enterprise software companies were not
good targets because they were older
then people who worked at consumer
internet company well and it may also be
the case that at first it's like well
selling just engineers and social
networking companies doesn't that limit
your market but it turns out that that's
the those are the people who will
respect the contrarian insights that you
had exactly and so then the leap of
faith becomes are there going to be more
people who respect that value
proposition over time and then we moved
into adjacent markets we got product
managers we got business development
people we got sales people at the
internet companies and then they went to
school with people and other professions
so we started getting doctors and
lawyers and and accountants and in
people in the investment business and it
just kept spreading and spreading and
spreading and we grew exponentially we
grew exponentially organically yeah I
remember when I first I first got it
just the idea that it will just
autopilot everything right is it the tax
loss harvesting all the the dynamic
balancing of your we didn't have all
that in the beginning but we've been
over time as we added more features we
appeal to ever broader audience and then
we had this insight last year
some people in the company were anxious
to hear what our vision was and so we
Adam made a huge investment over the
previous three years in our automation
engine in an hour advise engine to
things that others haven't done I've
gone for a walk with one of our product
managers and it sort of hit me that the
vision for the company was to optimize
and automate all of your finances and
then one of our engineers simplify that
to self-driving money that's where we
wanted to be now in order to do that we
had to offer a cash account because the
idea is that you would direct deposit
your paycheck with us we automatically
pay your bills and then route the
remaining money to the most appropriate
account be it a short-term account or a
long-term account via something that
pays a high-yield interest or something
that's investing and so we came out with
a cash account we put in a beta last
year and it came out in February and it
just exploded
and so now we've completely repositioned
around delivering a next-generation
banking service that's differentiated by
the fact that we will offer self-driving
money so we appeal to Millennials who
save where as all of the existing new
banks are focused on people who are
unbanked or are living paycheck to
paycheck well thanks for hanging with us
Andy always the players great to see you
always the place
thanks for listening to this interview
with me and Andy Radcliffe I wanted to
take a moment now to talk about a key
point that Andy made that I think is
essential for going for greatness
entrepreneurship can be described with a
two-by-two matrix on one dimension you
can be right or wrong and on the other
dimension you can be consensus or non
consensus you know obviously if you're
wrong you don't make money but what most
people don't realize is if you're right
in consensus you don't make money unless
you're non-consensus you don't have a
chance to serve the desperate because
they wouldn't be desperate if they were
already served if you aspire to create a
great startup consider one simple fact
great breakthroughs come from insights
that defy conventional wisdom Andy
Radcliffe refer to this as being non
consensus and right it floodgate we call
it insight development but the high
order bid is the same let's examine each
perspective starting with Andy Andy
pointed out that startup ideas have two
dimensions are you right or are you
wrong and are you consensus or non
consensus wrong is always bad because if
you're wrong you fail but it turns out
that just being right is not enough
either most people don't realize that if
you're right and consensus you'll
usually not achieve greatness your
startup might have a good idea but if
it's too obvious multiple me to
competitors will get funded by me to VCS
and as competition floods the market
prices erode sales cycles lengthen and
exit options become less compelling the
path to greatness is to be non-consensus
and right as soon as a business
opportunity becomes apparent to even a
small number of people the odds begin to
work against the startup I call this
effect the startup law of the jungle if
you've ever watched the nature Channel
and seen a baby wildebeest born on the
Serengeti plains of East Africa you can
get a visceral feel for what the typical
startup phases in its early days the
baby wildebeest is dropped out of its
mother's womb onto the ground at a wet
sac it could barely stand up and if the
baby animal takes more than five minutes
to get moving
it will find itself surrounded by hyenas
jackals and Nubian vultures in the
startup law of the jungle startups are
initially very vulnerable to the very
predators and hazards that surround them
being non-consensus and right affords
the startup the time to survive adapt
and succeed after trial and error
without fatal consequences no one preys
upon them because no one believes their
ideas important
this gives the startup time to master
differentiable and specific skills and
build strengths for the inevitable
competitive battles that will come in
the future
it floodgate we emphasize that insight
development should happen before
customer development this flows directly
from Andy Radcliffe's reasoning many of
you have heard of customer development
Andy mentioned it in our discussion it
was defined by Steve Blank and applies
the scientific method to getting product
market fit many subsequent works have
been built on Steve's theory in site
development happens even before customer
development it helps you figure out if
your idea is big enough before you even
get started one of the most valuable
lessons that Andy teaches us is that
insight is not the same as analysis you
can analyze customer pain when you start
your startup and the pain might be real
but that does not prove that your idea
is unique you can analyze a market for
gaps or white space but that doesn't
mean you've discovered something that no
one else is yet seen insight is about
knowing things that others don't know
yet insights are what help a startup get
an unfair advantage when they have very
few other advantages in site development
is a method we have learned from the
super performing founders when you
develop insights you ask different types
of questions that go beyond basic
analysis what is my arm secret what work
have I done to find something out that
others don't know how did I uncover the
secret why is it a secret what work did
I do to develop conviction that my
secret is real what is my why now almost
every startup idea has been tried
shouldn't I assume that my ideas been
tried who's tried something similar why
did they not succeed has there been any
major technology change event that makes
something possible only now is there
increasing adoption of a technology that
makes something possible only now why is
now the time for your idea to happen in
future episodes we will talk lots about
insight development but speaking of now
what does this all mean for you you must
commit yourself to having a real insight
if you want to be truly great all of the
greatest breakthroughs came from
unconventional insights the theory of
gravity Euclidean geometry the solar
system all these ideas were put forward
by heretics in their time so my own
quote I will leave you with is there's a
right kind of crazy if you like this
interview please subscribe to my podcast
starting greatness for each week I'll
share an interview with a legendary
founder a thought leader like Marc
Andreessen Reed Hoffman Steve Blank and
more each interview will be accompanied
by a deeper exploration of a key lesson
of the super performers in order to
provide you actionable insights as you
pursue your own path to greatness you
can follow me on twitter @ m2 jr. and
please shoot me an email with any
comments or questions to greatness at
floodgate comm and if you like the show
I'd be grateful if you could leave us a
review on Apple podcasts never let go of
your inner power to do great things in
whatever matters to you and until we
meet again remember greatness is a
decision
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek calm all the
spell out and just drop it if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode of the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by 99 designs
99 designs is a global creative platform
makes it easy for you to find an amazing
designer and create designs you'll love
and logos to branding to packaging to
books you name it they have it and I've
used them for just about everything 99
designs is the go to creative resource
for any budget I've used them for years
now for book covers for instance
mock-ups of before our body which went
on to become a number one here comes for
seller illustrations for the multi
volume cowl of Seneca including the
cover and many other creative projects
I've been very impressed by the quality
of their work most recently I used 99
designs to update the illustrations in
layout of my 5 morning rituals eBook the
illustrations worked out great I loved
working with the designer we selected
and I plan to work with him on more
projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest
simply submit a brief on the site
describing what you need and designers
who are interested in your project often
from around the world will submit
concepts for you to choose from you'll
find as you go give feedback and once
you're ready you choose one to finalize
it's a great way to get started and find
the right match a great designer and a
great design at a great price so head to
99designs com4 slash tim to learn more
or get started today you can also see
examples of some of the work that I have
done with designers online that size
let's check it out 99designs comm
forward slash tip this episode is
brought to you by pellet ah I love
peloton peloton is a cutting edge indoor
cycling bike that brings live studio
classes right to your home you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
your schedule making it to the studio or
dealing with some commute to the gym I
have a follow time bike in my master
bedroom at home and it is one of the
first things that I do in the morning I
wake up meditate Percy 20 minutes and
then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
usually high-intensity interval training
or hit then I take shower and I'm in
higher gear for the rest of the day it's
beautifully convenient and has become
something that I actually look forward
to and I was skeptical in the beginning
I didn't think I would dig it and I
really do you have a lot of options for
one if you like you can ride live with
thousands of other pollen riders from
across the country on the interactive
leaderboard to be motivated I tend to
use a lot of the classes on demand and
have four to six of them that I've
bookmarked and use over and over again
there are up to fourteen new classes
every day with thousands of classes on
demand and there are a variety of
workouts to choose from 45 minute
classes 20 minute burns hip hop rock and
roll low impact or high-intensity pick
the class structure and style their
works for you peloton has an amazing
roster of incredible instructors in New
York City you really do have great
instructors of every possible
personality his style and that you can
find one that you love no matter what
you're in the mood for personally I use
Matt wolbers a lot but I use a bunch of
them I'm promiscuous and enjoy classes
from a lot of their instructors with
real time metrics you can track your
performance over time and continue to
beat your personal bests
I do not think the gamification would
work for me and they really
hit the nail on the head it does work at
least for me tremendously well to keep
me pushing consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to do experience to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer go to one
peloton comm that's spelled o and e PL o
t om calm
enter the code tim podcast all one word
at checkout and get $100 off accessories
with your palette on bike purchase get a
great workout at home any time you want
go to one peloton calm and use the code
tim podcast to get started
[Applause]